bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24 hoy los llevaremos a sudán
la explotación de petróleo en el estado
de west kordofán en sudán que contiene
una de las mayores reservas petrolíferas
en el país africano está provocando un
impacto negativo en la población y en el
ambiente pérdida de tierras de pastoreo
deforestación contaminación del suelo y
el agua y problemas de salud se cuentan
entre las consecuencias que ha dejado la
extracción de crudo debido a la falta de
estándares ambientales son los
habitantes de zonas cercanas a los
campos petroleros ingieren residuos de
aceite a través del agua contaminada
situación que ha generado un aumento de
enfermedades abortos espontáneos y
numerosas malformaciones en los recién
nacidos según investigadores muestras de
sangre tomadas a los locales y al ganado
han revelado la presencia de metales
pesados los aldeanos han ignorado
durante mucho tiempo los peligros de
esta explotación del oro libro llevará a
cabo en el marco de la cooperación chino
zhu organiza un hummer farat de france24
junto a un consorcio de periodistas de
investigación realizaron el siguiente
reportaje sobre el lado oscuro de la
industria petrolera de sudan
[Música]
este estado del kordofán occidental
salen las heridas de un diseño de guerra
de territorio con su vecino del sur
bajo estas tierras áridas fluye una de
las reservas de petróleo más importantes
de sudán
aquí nadie se imaginaba a pagar tan caro
el precio del oro negro
el jefe de este pueblo ubicado a algunos
kilómetros de la explotación petrolera
más grande
se atreve a hablar por primera vez
frente a nuestra cámara
antes de la explotación petrolera
teníamos tierras fértiles nuestro ganado
contaba con buena salud nuestras mujeres
no sufrían abortos espontáneos u otros
males la llegada del petróleo causó
problemas de salud para nuestras mujeres
y el medio ambiente que también cardio
en este pueblo los abortos espontáneos
se han multiplicado durante los últimos
cinco años varios niños sufren de
discapacidad o malformaciones
abdel rauf tiene tres años y nunca
caminará
y sus problemas de salud aparecieron
poco tiempo después del inicio de la
producción petrolera con nuestra familia
no había antecedentes de enfermedades
pero tras el descubrimiento del petróleo
empezamos a tener casos y estos niños
tienen hoy en día entre ocho meses y
cuatro años y medio
antes no existirá alguien duplicado mal
esta mujer perdió a uno de sus hijos el
año pasado luego de problemas
respiratorios su pequeña hija de ocho
meses nació con esta malformación en la
boca que le impide alimentarse
correctamente
[Música]
por supuesto que sus deformaciones se
deben al petróleo
la leche sale de su boca en cuanto
tratamos de matarla
la verdad
y dejándonos
[Música]
el doctor moghadam es investigador sobre
el medio ambiente en la universidad de
las ciencias y de la tecnología en su
verdad
para ser alguien
para nuestra investigación le pedimos
que me diera los impactos de la
industria petrolera en la salud y el
medio ambiente
durante dos días su equipo extrajo
muestras de agua tierra y sangre que
fueron llevadas a jartúm para ser
analizadas
la mayoría de las personas con las que
nos reunimos confirmaron que antes de la
producción petrolera estas enfermedades
no existían en estas proporciones
[Música]
estas mujeres permiten las tomas de
sangre
todas han sufrido abortos espontáneos
durante los últimos años
vive en el barça allá si vivo aquí
entonces usted nació y creció aquí sí ha
tenido abortos espontáneos otros hijos
tuve un aborto espontáneo
usted tuvo un aborto espontáneo una vez
o más de una vez una sola vez
o más para fulminar y no es similar
le haremos una toma de sangre para ver
si está infectada o no
o azules
[Aplausos]
la explotación del campo petrolero sudán
stars empezó en 2012 en al barça ya es
gestionado por la sociedad de estado en
aquella época el gobierno de omar al
bashir trata de desarrollar lo más
rápido posible la producción petrolera
sin regulación
un año antes sudan del sur y xosé sesión
y jartúm perdió más del 70 por ciento de
sus recursos petroleros
[Música]
en cuanto cayó omar al bachir en 2019
tras 30 años de un poder autoritario la
juventud le pidió cuentas
[Música]
el colectivo de los jóvenes del petróleo
documentó minuciosamente las
responsabilidades de las compañías
petroleras
[Música]
y en especial la explosión del pozo 49
en alarte en 2019
un campo petrolero explotado por la
compañía china pequeños
acudimos al lugar de la explosión
acompañados por mohamed y aisha miembro
del colectivo
de lavar son pozos petroleros hicieron
parte de un gran campo petrolero
muy rápido los guardas nos impiden
grabar vinimos a buscar informaciones
ingresamos por la puerta verdad la
puerta no está aquí de acuerdo pero
venimos al lugar de la explosión y me
pides que vaya al cuartel general son
los procedimientos
la empresa china se apresuró a borrar
los rastros de la explosión en el lugar
pero los estigmas en las víctimas son
indelebles
hola cómo estás
hola
es él quien cerró el curso 49
nos reunimos con un ex empleado de la
compañía petrolera china la matula tiene
25 años
usted petrolero durante el incidente que
le dijeron
había trabajado la noche anterior un
chino me despertó durante mi descanso y
me pidió que fuera de inmediato al pozo
me negué aduciendo que no estaba
trabajando y me respondió oh vas o te
despido
cuando llegue al lugar sólo llevaba un
casco de protección con el viento se
perdió recibía aceite en bruto sobre la
cara y la oreja derecha duró más de tres
horas como recompensa el chino nos
ofreció un paquete de azúcar y una caja
de leche nada más
y a pesar de su valentía la empresa
china lo despidió
5 fuimos despedidos
me dijeron que debido a mi problema de
oído ya no me necesitaba
china aliada de siempre del presidente
al bachir aislado por los occidentales
en los años 90 jartúm es acusado por
estados unidos de patrocinar el
terrorismo internacional y queda bajo
embargo económico para las compañías
petroleras chinas se precipitan a la
grieta muy rápidamente sudan se vuelve
una bendición petrolera para china
representando el 40 por ciento de su
producción en el extranjero
el petróleo abunda despreciando las
normas sanitarias o medioambientales y a
cambio de promesas de desarrollo tras la
revolución es la doctora taher quien
insta a las nuevas autoridades a crear
un comité para confrontarse al espinoso
expediente del petróleo
todos a los que les hablamos del
petróleo temen porque debido a la mano
de hierro temen por su seguridad la
gente vivido en el temor porque el
petróleo estaba bajo el control del
aparato de seguridad del estado omar al
bachir dejó la administración del
departamento petrolero al servicio de
seguridad e inteligencia y con los
chinos nadie sabía lo que ocurría tan
solo el impacto negativo en sus vidas
que observaban todos los días
las promesas de desarrollo quedaron como
letra muerta
aquí a la población le hace falta de
todo
incluso agua
y
la gente ve en estos recipientes de
plástico usados para la producción de
petróleo
los llenan de agua para que la gente
beba pero también beben residuos de
petróleo
cayetana
eso provoca cáncer abortos espontáneos y
alergias
o la antigua la que somos litros
el agua es un recurso indispensable pero
es una fuente de sufrimiento para los
sudaneses de la región todo ello debido
al petróleo
hola cómo está
está sucio y aceite basta con mirar y
ver lo sucio que está
sin embargo la mayoría de la población
debe ver esa agua estancada infectada es
lo que ustedes utiliza bebe agua con
esto porque si está sucio no lo
limpiaron
tomamos una nueva muestra estos
recipientes contaminados se volvieron
las principales fuentes de agua de estos
habitantes por falta de infraestructura
pública
estos recipientes son la fuente de
enfermedades y catástrofes
quienes controlan estos grupos
petroleros vendieron los recipientes a
los habitantes a veces a precios muy
elevados
sin advertirnos sobre el peligro
y por supuesto estos recipientes son una
especie de veneno portable
me iba a adaptar
de regreso a jartúm entregamos las
muestras a un laboratorio reconocido
[Música]
a la espera de los resultados vamos a la
sede de la compañía china petro energy y
grabamos discretamente
su empresa está instalada aquí desde
hace años y ustedes tenían el compromiso
de desarrollo en la región sin embargo
no hicieron nada observamos que no era
posible desplazarse cuando llovía porque
no había vías asfaltadas y no hay
escuelas ello hacía parte de sus
compromisos porque las promesas no
fueron respetadas
usted hace preguntas puedo decirle que
tenemos una respuesta convincente pero
se lo repito no podemos contestarle
no podemos hablarles a los medios sin
autorización previa quiere que tengamos
problemas con el gobierno
pero la compañía pertenece a china y no
al estado sabe más que nosotros
la empresa está relacionada con el
estado la empresa trabaja en beneficio
del estado en nombre del estado
no recibirán mejor en la compañía
pública tarifa que explota el campo de
al barça ya
tarija abdelrahmán avanza tomó la
dirección hace algunos meses
ya no pretendo que la industria
petrolera no tenga efectos negativos en
la gente y el medio ambiente no se puede
negar pero tampoco se puede afirmar que
los casos de
la producción petrolera
y hay pruebas que deben ser realizadas
por laboratorios médicos sociales y por
expertos
los resultados confirmarán los temores
de la población
revelan la presencia de metales pesados
en las muestras de sangre tomadas en los
habitantes y su ganado cadmio un metal
que no existe en estado natural y plomo
el informe final demuestra que estos
metales provienen de las actividades en
la zona en la medida que la producción
petrolera es la única los expertos
concluyen que las compañías petroleras
son responsables del surgimiento de
abortos espontáneos malformaciones o
discapacidades
hasta aquí el programa de reporteros de
la semana recuerde que para sintonizar
este y los programas anteriores puede
ingresar a nuestra página web france24
puntocom hasta la próxima